♪ (intro music) ♪
Give me one minute
and I'll show you
how Google Cloud Operations Suite
can help you monitor and troubleshoot
your infrastructure and applications.
The tools in the Suite provide
deep insights and best practices
that help your team's developer,
operations, DevOps, and SREs
utilize Google SRE principles.
It captures signals,
monitors systems and services,
and helps troubleshoot issues.
With built-in telemetry
for Google services,
out-of-box dashboards
define and manage
alerts, recommendations, and more.
The tools include Monitoring, Logging,
and advanced observabilities,
such as Trace, Debugger, and Profiler.
Cloud Logging aggregates
log data at scale
from all your infrastructure
and applications
into a single location.
This enables users to search and analyze
large volumes of log
to troubleshoot problems quickly,
and gives you full control to decide
how and where to start the logs.
Cloud Monitoring
provides visibility of health
across your apps and infrastructure,
regardless of where it is.
You can even define custom metrics
unique to your use case
and send them to external systems.
Using Metrics Explorer
and Monitoring Query Language,
you can analyze these metrics
and can even set alerts and SLOs.
Advanced observability feature Trace
provides insight into request flow,
service topology,
and latency issues in your app.
Debugger allows you to inspect
running applications after deployment,
without needing to stop or slow down.
And Profiler continually analyzes
your code's performance on each service
so you can improve its speed
and reduce your cost.
While Trace tracks relationships
and latency between services,
Profiler tracks this
across individual functions
in your code base,
and Debugger helps find the root cause.
You can use the Cloud Console or the API
to use Cloud Operation tools.
All cloud capabilities offer
a very generous free tier
to make it easy for you to get started.
So next time you're looking
for an observability solution,
take a minute to look at Cloud Operations.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/product/operations